hey welcome to a new project camp update
so yeah we've been reading the youtube
comments new people new video maker new
style we're gonna talk more about that
at the end of this video but first i'm
gonna show you some benches that we
renovated talk more about the yoga decks
and we actually started making a height
map so we have an overview of the land
[Music]
so by now we have a pretty good overview
of the land thanks to walking around and
just being able to fly the drone
but one thing we need is an elevation
map
it's a height map that shows the
different heights and contour lines on
the land
and we need this to plan our landscapes
and the water flows
so we started using some online tools to
make this with the help of the online
community we found this very useful tool
that makes contour lines using satellite
information
moritz used data and made this map
still found a plugin for blender and
made this 3d model
and yanovic combined some other data
together and mainly modeled the 3d model
from it
and these are all very cool maps but all
based on somewhat low resolution
satellite data that is freely available
so you want to give it another test and
map it out with a drone
so mark was actually on his way to make
a big trip to europe in his green van
and wanted to drop by for a few days to
help out
but yeah so he was coming to project
camp but he had a few obstacles first
[Music]
is
[Music]
with their hands
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes yeah
[Music]
[Music]
if we just drag it it's perfect
[Music]
okay guys
we're working on a height map for
project camp
and
the drone has has been doing uh the
work today uh all morning we had rain
but there was a window
where weather was pretty good for it
so we went for it
the drone itself
does most of the work
i've got an app
it's actually a free app from
pix4d
and it
it controls the drone automatically so
it flies a pattern and
photo takes photographs from
overland
can you operate from from here also the
drone well not while it's doing this
this is all an automatic system
yeah
where is it
okay this is uh this is the pattern
the drone flew and you see a little
camera on all the spots
and then
it had to sync
the photos and now we have a list of
photos from the land
it's all straight from above so it will
generate a
3d map from from this information now we
can see
the shape it has generated from the
point cloud and it doesn't have the
texture on it yet
it's so here we are now again
with
uh the fully textured mesh
because it's a bit bit low rest because
the
high-res versions will get
so
large it would be
unworkable actually
you can still see all the the the entire
grid of cameras
floating above
the land
so gives a
great look on how this
this is created by
computing power in the software and the
drone and me
i hope you enjoy it
since we become more people because the
first helpers arrived to support the
project we needed a bigger table to sit
together eat and work on
i am jeannie here for some weeks to help
and i work usually in the movie industry
my job is to find and buy secondhand
stuff for movies
so it was easy and fun for me to find
some nice old restaurant tables in a
portuguese second-hand website
julie adrian and me drove to the place
made a good deal with the guy and bought
them
now we just have to show them a bit of
love and they will be good as new
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Applause]
genie what have you been doing
we removed all the paint and then we
took some sandpaper to remove it
and now
we put on some linseed oil to protect
the
tables from bad weather
[Music]
i'm trying to remove these parts
screws are broken
rust
that's fine
so you need to screw through the metal
and you need to take out the screws the
broken
[Music]
i could also break it
[Music]
[Music]
we already took away
the old parts that were a bit rotten and
with all the screws all rusty
so
and they were weak
so now we are replacing them for new
parts that are going to hold the legs
yeah way more stronger new screws
will last way longer
[Music]
[Music]
i think they should be the same
[Music]
seems good
[Music]
i think it's
up
[Music]
[Music]
if it doesn't go as when the food is all
on the table
[Music]
i like it very much because on the table
is always can you give me that can you
give me that also new desk
people
flying needles
your destination is on the left now but
there was nothing there but um
[Music]
last week you could see us choosing a
location for the yoga decks which will
be in the rocky area it has a great view
over the land
we are building a few wooden decks on
the land as a place to relax calm down
and do some exercise
we feel more and more that besides of
the essential infrastructure like a
kitchen a workspace and so on it's
important to create spaces where people
can come and have fun or empty their
mind from all that daily functional
stuff
we had a few talks together and what
they should look like and how to build
them we decided to give them the soft
shape of a pebble to fit to the
environment the function of the decks
here you can see the final design the
decks will be made of wood and we try to
place them on the rocks without drilling
in the stone
so when we move them they won't leave
the trays
the decks will not be connected to each
other but placed on different spots
around the environment for the sake of
research we want for each deck a
different type of food we hope to find
more about the behavioral wood types in
this climate over a longer period of
time
more about this in the next videos you
can also find the research topic on the
website
hey hello dear youtube subscriber
so
yeah let's talk a bit more about this
new video style that is going on here on
the project camp youtube channel
and so in the recent weeks we
released few new videos and they look a
bit different than before and we got
some comments on that
some people really like it new style
good music
coup d'audio looks super nice nice shots
some people prefer the old style where
it's a bit more
logical straightforward about
development
and the main reason why it changed is
that last year i made the videos
and this year we have a new video maker
here that is helping us out making these
videos
and the main reason actually for getting
a video maker is that it just became too
much for me to organize a project and
also make videos each week and it's just
not scalable i mean if you're here with
two people we might manage but the
project is gonna be bigger than that and
the plan is to have a whole lot of
people here with a whole lot of projects
so we need to have a more scalable
solution
so for that for season two we decided to
have a video maker one person that is
really dedicated on the ground to make
sure whatever is going on here is
captured and shown to you guys
yeah so i think we're now a bit at this
difficult point of trying to maneuver
between
different people making the videos but i
think you should really see it as felix
is here in a way really to serve you
guys because we have a lot going on on
the land a lot of projects a lot of
development and he is here to document
it in a way that is interesting useful
and relevant for you guys to watch
so it's very much up to you guys to tell
us like how do you want to see it and
what do you think it should be shown
because then we would sort of adapt to
that and obviously we need to make sure
that people here are happy how it goes
and the people on youtube are happy
difficult sometimes for us in the
youtube comments to find out what is
relevant and what not but i guess
hopefully we will get better at that as
well
but yeah so it's going to be an ongoing
process we'll take a few episodes before
we nail it down but it's going to be
good for the long term video making of
project cam so hopefully you guys stick
around and help us out in the process
anyway that was it for this video thanks
for watching if you already want to see
the next one make sure to support on
patreon if not we'll just see you next
week
bye